thank you
all right number 248 you have the
speediest hand
hi fellas uh just to the back over here
uh it's Mike Bennigan from the UK press
Association told you I'd see you on
Sunday didn't I yeah so guys congrats
massive congrats and uh I guess first
question is
how does it feel to have just created
the sweetest moment of the Oscars 2023.
James Martin who is the the Beating
Heart of our film you know it's his
birthday today this was always the
second most important thing of the day
as Tom said so we just wanted to make
sure that he had an extra special moment
and yeah it was amazing to have
everybody singing for him in the Dolby
Theater are ridiculous
and next up we have number two
two seven before we head over to our
virtual Press Room
hi IFA Barry here from Dublin how are
things congratulations over here
um I know everybody in Ireland Northern
Ireland and Britain is just so excited
um about your win I just wanted to ask
what that means to you that you're
bringing together the island of Ireland
and Britain and that idea of
collaboration and working together do
you think you'll that will kind of be a
lesson from your win here that people
might be inspired by Across the two
neighboring Islands I hope so I mean I'm
the English part of this English Irish
Duo so I'm going to defer to you again
on this one
look yeah I think you know I come from
Northern Ireland identity is a complex
thing for us in Northern Ireland our
pace is an adolescent piece it's a
fragile piece always but we are so proud
of the pace and everybody I know wants
to ensure that is protected so look I
think our crew who came together to make
this film they were from the Republic of
Ireland from Britain from Northern
Ireland and we're just so proud to have
this collaborative way of making this
film together yeah
um and yeah we're so thrilled to um
hopefully as you said there's a bit of
Legacy there but look we're just really
proud to be representing Northern
Ireland uh and and the sort of the
message and the project that is Northern
Ireland and what that means to people
thank you so much and next up we're
moving to the virtual press room where
we have the Irish times and then we'll
move over to number 201 the Irish Times
please go ahead
hi boys
um Donald Clark here from the Irish
Times I told you I told you I'd be
talking to you didn't I
all right
um talk about the experience of being
part of an Irish wave this year um with
14 nominations all those nominations for
Banshees and Paul mezclan and so forth
did you feel part of a team as a result
of that
yeah look it's been a special year for
Ireland and we feel thrilled to be such
a small part of that we know we're a
small part of it but you know the guys
have all been so welcoming to us the
guys from and Colleen Kuhn who've made
such a beautiful film uh Martin
McDonough whose work we just wouldn't be
here without uh you know all those
nominees Inspire us so much and they've
been so generous with us and yeah it's
it's made the journey feel extra special
feel like we're part of this strange
little Club of Irish nominees so yeah
we're really honored to be a small part
of that
all right number two Euro one and then
three three six seven
are those
congratulations what an amazing
achievement
um firstly can you just put into words
what it's like to accept an Oscar here
tonight and secondly where is the after
party
I don't remember anything that happened
after walking up to the stage I think I
saw Paul maskel turning around looking
fairly happy for us got onto the stage
and after that it's just it's it's all a
blur we got backstage had a bit of a cry
together all four of us
um it just snuck away to a little corner
and had a little moment this is a long
way away from rural Northern Ireland
where the story began it's bizarre to
think of the chasm that is between you
know where this film comes from a short
filmmaker's emerging filmmakers you
never set out
on a project thinking that you are going
to end up anywhere near any applaudits
or anything like this so this is beyond
icing cherry on the cake I don't know
what's on the cake at this stage tastes
good and to answer the most important
part of your question parties at our
goth yeah
[Music]
and last question three
three congratulations
I just remind you what happened
everybody sang happy birthday that's
correct yeah
um he made a beautiful film about human
connections and also you know
testimonies to to mothers Etc what's
your what's been your most beautiful
human moments with this whole experience
with your cast and crew and any message
you've got for them it's been just that
it's been us uh with with James Martin
and Seamus Sahara you know our Leading
Men um to be able to go on this journey
crazy Journey with them
um is is wonderful you know it's so
difficult on on short projects to build
up any sense of kind of camaraderie or
friendship because you don't have a lot
of time but what this experience has
given us is an extended life of the film
that's just allowed us as as filmmakers
and actors to kind of come together be
together throughout all of it and that's
what I'll be most thankful for looking
back is just to have as much time with
with Ross and the boys
um and yeah we're now the the best of
friends and that is something that will
endure forever
thank you all very much